so when i retired the first time in 2017
burroughs was the only current like
we'll say really elite level wrestler
that i never trained with um i was
really good friends with nebraska's head
coach still am and i said hey i just
want i'm going to pay my own way i want
to train with jordan's i want to see
what it feels like you know i want to
get in there and mix it up i mix it up
with david taylor and kyle dake i mean
there's just some adult wrestling that i
love
and so i flew myself down there in
january of 2018 and i spent four days
training with jordan it was a really
good time it gave me some great insight
into how he thinks and you know what a
great champion is
what was the like training with him like
what can you get some insights yeah of
course like what the
like how hard is the the live training
is it more drilling is it technical like
how does his
it seems like his style is very
different than yours so how does that
match up in the room in terms of like
what you learn from each other that kind
of thing we went full life for one i
think it was like 12 or 15 minutes ago
where we just go wrestle um we did a
bunch of simulated live but obviously he
he had so i was a senior in college when
he was a freshman in nebraska and so we
our teams had dueled each other he was
obviously a lot smaller at that point in
time um but he had followed my career
and so when i went in there it was like
hey i know you're really good at this
position what about this position what
are you trying to do how exactly does it
work and then let's wrestle there you
know and then hey what about this
position and so you know we would
spend 30 to 40 minutes talking about
that position on the ground or it was
like one was the chest wrap it wasn't
for headlock one was uh i don't know
it's called what we call the lightning
dump but
the lightning dome yeah
my buddy's name was lightning luke smith
in high school and he was the first
person i saw do it so usually when i see
someone do something then i name that
move after them got it um
i know right great name it's a good so
uh yeah but so what i said with that is
like
okay he was still trying to be the best
in the world i was just trying to go
work out jordan burroughs because i
enjoy wrestling yeah um
is like someone who at that point when
he has five world titles at that four or
five at that point a lot
and so you see my high school kids is
like hey this this is the guy who's the
best in the world
who's bringing someone in and saying how
do i do this how do i do that what about
this what about that and so the level of
inquisition is inclusive
that's a hard word inquisitiveness he
has
is really impressive and then it's
obvious why he got to the level he did
because he's figuring out all these
little situations and that's honestly
one of the biggest things i think
wrestlers
a lot of wrestlers fail to do as they
get older even when they get to early
college age they say this is my style
this is what i do i'm gonna lift and
work out hard and i'm
and i'm not gonna anything in my game
you know whereas
you've seen many progressions in jordan
bros games he just made his 10th world
team
and yeah and you know if you have a
really keen eye you've been able to
watch him change
you know i've been watching him since
2007.
he's changed so much
and obviously still maintained a
world-class level almost the entire time
when you say change like what changed
because he's he's got that double leg
yeah but you're saying double anymore
was that he like hit his double leg for
the first time because alex did he hit
him in years yeah so that's like when
people think about jordan bros they
think about the double leg because in
his early years
fire he had a great double lick right
and even so in those years i would say
the the biggest thing with jordan bros
double leg was it his level of
explosiveness it was his level of
persistence he would shoot and shoot and
shoot and shoot and it would a lot of
times would be from fun creative angles
and out of scrambles boom also he's on
you you know and just he was just super
persistent with it and i think that was
probably the key
and then you saw
you know when he came out to won the
first world championship in 2011 it was
kind of that type of mentality and then
shortly after then obviously everyone
was starting to lower their stance
getting lower and he developed a really
good like mantis go behind series where
he would go one way the other way then
he started developing a really good like
low single ankle pick type thing you
know and then his his hand fighting got
really tremendous like 15 16 17 his hand
fighting was really good and now i just
commented at the 21 trials like
a few of the defensive sequences you got
into it's like holy [ __ ] like just not
from an athletic team but from a
technical standpoint the things he were
doing was just tremendous so i've seen
him as someone like who's continued to
reinvent themselves over the course of
the last 10 12 years
especially in the as a junior and senior
in college you were exceptionally
dominant yeah if you were to face him at
the peak both of your peaks of ncaa
wrestling could you uh could you beat
him and if you can beat him
well of course you can beat him yeah uh
how do you solve the jordan borrows well
uh so for a folk style wrestling stance
folk style yeah
so you know he he had some competitive
matches his junior senior year he had a
2-1 win over uh or maybe 3-2 over
michael chandler who was my teammate
who's fighting uc now he had a
two-on-one over tyler caldwell um so i
think you can glean some insight into
that you know he got written
he got so mad about this up on a podcast
so during chrono we had to make up all
kinds of [ __ ] to talk about yeah and
we were doing like the last 10 years
best 165s and i said kyle dake would
ride him for over a minute oh wow he got
so mad you want to come on the podcast
the next day so hopefully he doesn't
listen to this like [ __ ] you man you
know um but you know what when was this
this is during corona corona last year
he got mad we were talking about we were
before the trials yeah correct yeah so
um
yeah michael channel wrote him for two
minutes plus and that was his junior
year not a senior year sure right but
it's close
um so i think there's some things there
i think the interesting thing would be
if i would have stuck around right so i
chose to go into mixed martial arts
after 2008 i would have been 74 and he
would have been 74 so we would have to
wrestle and then i think that the
freestyle jordan burroughs puzzle is a
lot more difficult to solve than the
folk style jordan bros puzzle and i
think i don't think he would i think he
would acknowledge that
he's much better freestyle than he was
at folk style oh you know although he
was very good he's better this is like
raw speed explosiveness um presents a
problem to you well so he was never i
mean he didn't ex really excel on the
mat in kind of either style in freestyle
he has got some good lace transitions
but in folks that like his whole like in
his entire college career think he has
like 10 pins which is almost nothing you
know so he was gaining no value off the
top position he was good enough on most
people to get off bottom without it
being an issue but it wasn't like oh my
gosh this is an area where we have to be
careful there's a lot of things here
you know it's just he wasn't gaining
value there whereas in freestyle he
i don't say never but the amount of
times he gets turned is incredibly rare
very very rare um and he does have a
glaze transition so he gets a lot of
points there so and obviously freestyle
is
it can be geared way more in the neutral
position right we're only doing takedown
so
you